cada día kabul se despierta con el
sonido de explosiones y tiroteos el
ejército la policía afgana y ahora
también los militantes de la sociedad
civil los defensores de los derechos
humanos los empleados del gobierno y los
periodistas todos son un blanco 65
militantes de la sociedad civil y
periodistas han sido asesinados a lo
largo de estos últimos tres años entre
las redacciones en duelo se encuentra la
de la cadena de televisión privada 1 tv
estos son los periodistas que murieron
cuando estalló una bomba en la rotonda
judge de arak en kabul en 2018 logró
salir a javi y gas y razón y hoy en día
los reporteros están directamente en la
mira antes lo estaban pero no de manera
individual
muchos periodistas se han ido del país
la mayor parte de nuestras colegas
mujeres se dejaron su trabajo y su
seguridad es lo más importante y aquí no
está garantizada samaranch es uno de los
pocos reporteros de 1tb en seguir
trabajando en el terreno
el reportero ha resultado herido dos
veces en ataques ocurridos durante sus
reportajes desde hace tres meses las
conferencias de la redacción no se hacen
a distancia al otro lado de la línea dos
dirigentes de la cadena están exiliados
en el extranjero después de haber
recibido amenazas una centena de jefes
de distritos han sido nombrados le
pedimos detalles al ministerio del
interior pero no se encargan de ese
asunto
[Música]
a causa de las amenazas a algunos de
nuestros colegas trabajan desde su casa
a lo largo de los últimos dos meses las
amenazas de asesinatos dirigidos han
aumentado muchos periodistas han muerto
en la provincia de helmand y en kabul
los servicios de seguridad nos dijeron
cuídense más el pasado 17 de enero dos
mujeres juezas de la corte suprema-
fallecieron bajo las balas de un grupo
de hombres armados en el corazón de
kabul el ataque se produjo a unos
cuantos pasos de la residencia de una de
ellas se despidió de nosotros y salió
cuatro minutos después escuché unos
disparos salimos corriendo a la calle
vimos el vehículo detenido mi hermana
estaba en la parte de atrás muerta
alrededor de 300 mujeres son juezas en
afganistán símbolo de un gran progreso
desde la caída de los talibanes en 2001
cuyo régimen les prohibía a las mujeres
trabajar
ella trabajaba desde hacía 34 años y le
encantaba su trabajo su país su pueblo
su familia había viajado a francia a
eeuu a corea le dije varias veces que no
volviera al país que se quedara allá a
causa de la situación aquí
siempre se negó me decía adoro mi país y
quiero regresar acá el gobierno no la
supo proteger ningún miembro de la corte
suprema- vino a presentarnos sus
condolencias porque temen por su
seguridad pero no les importa la
seguridad de sus jueces los empleados
del gobierno también están en la mira de
los insurgentes hace tres años fer está
justa iniciadas empleado de la
municipalidad y antigua campeona de
taekwondo escapó a la muerte fue
agredida por unos hombres que la
esperaban cerca de su casa
escuchar
traté de defenderme me hicieron aquí en
la mano eran tres con cuchillos trataron
de apuñalar me en el estómago pero no lo
lograron tengo cicatrices por todo el
cuerpo me hirieron en el codo en la
rodilla en el pie y en la mano
[Música]
en todo el país las mujeres son
particularmente perseguidas
ya que tiene afganistán las mujeres no
tienen ningún derecho
ya sabéis que quiere que las mujeres no
salgan que trabajen como esclavas en la
casa mayor acostada de tal forma por eso
no puedo decir que sólo los talibanes
están detrás de esos ataques
devastadores deben provenir de varios
grupos muy conservadores hay bastante
emisiones de genes que no quieren que
haya progreso en afganistán
y nos encontramos con una mano que hace
un reportaje en un barrio donde viven
familias de desplazados internos
instalados en kabul para huir de los
combates en sus regiones
ammán fue contactado por un
representante local que le avisó sobre
el caso de esta niña pequeña de 8 años
casada a la fuerza con este niño de 14
años
y maltratada por su familia política
vas a la escuela
tienes noticias de tu madre y de tu
padre en afganistán hay muchos temas que
se deben documentar la pobreza los
problemas económicos la inseguridad los
matrimonios forzados en los matrimonios
de menores debemos cubrir todo esto nos
arriesgamos al estar en el terreno pero
es nuestro deber nos aman frank podría
pagar caro su osadía como muchos otros
el desenlace de las negociaciones de paz
que elabora en el futuro de afganistán
es incierto al igual que el contenido
del acuerdo del cual nada parece indicar
que protegerá a los militantes de la
sociedad civil